and joining us from the floor of the
international auto show in frankfurt is
Matthias Mueller the CEO of Porsche
thanks for taking the time to speak with
us we've just seen one of your factory
drivers training for a big motor race
with a Porsche hybrid engine is that the
future even for Portia's less Taylor
Street models
if possible I want to remember you that
we have been the first competitor who
has offered three plug-in hybrid cars in
series with the Panamera busy cayenne
and busy 918 spyder and also our limo
winner cars in 919 hybrid is a plug-in
hybrid technology so we are convinced
about the technology we have been very
successful and we will develop it also
for the future now the next step is a
mobility considering the Porsche driver
stereotypes will your customers accept
an electric engine that doesn't have
that primitive gut wrenching porsche raw
I'm fully convinced that our customers
will accept eco from Porsche but it must
be a real Porsche with all the
technology features which are successful
for Porsche for example it must be
powerful it must have a very nice design
it must be a good have a good package
and it must have facts and figures which
are better than that of the competition
for example you should go 500 kilometres
with 250 km/h and the stop too full to
full the tank should not be longer than
15 minutes talking of success many
German carmakers are currently feeling
the pinch in China is China a problem
for Porsche to and how is your company
shielding itself from cooling markets
it's no problem in China but they's
friendly spoken a tough competition but
we did our homework we have a very
attractive product portfolio we
developed our dealer network in the in
the last year's and we do it also in the
future so we accept that we are in a
tough competition but we are convinced
that we are successful in the future a
final question you've studied mechanics
and computer science which must surely
come in handy considering the
developments in the automobile industry
how IT savvy will future motorists need
to be
it is a new challenge for the car
industry but nevertheless we have to do
that we know that the smartphone
technology is very important and the
customers will expect all these futures
also in the cars that means that we and
our competitors have to do a lot of work
to make sure that the customer as is
convenient in our cars and what we also
want to do is to give opportunities to
have a better flow in the engine traffic
for example porsche CEO Matthias Mueller
thanks for joining us on made in Germany